oh my gosh wow it is so nice to meet you
this is so pretty happy birthday by the
way thank you i wish i want someone to
buy me a fanny pack now like i didn't
know you could it was that dangerous
that's amazing that fanny pack yeah we
had an amazing time making that yeah
it's really cool how long did it take to
do that just that one fanny pack scene
like to learn all of that well it took
weeks i trained with the action team for
weeks uh and you know because when
you're in a movie with michelle yo yeah
and those action sequence i mean she is
the queen of martial arts so yeah i i
you know i i wanted to make sure that i
i did a good job so i trained for weeks
with our action team in fact i even
brought the fanny pack home uh and
trained and imagine the fanny pack is
six to seven feet long and i was
constantly swinging that thing in the
house what so i was swinging it
practicing it to make sure i perfected
it
and the thing is my wife wasn't too
happy because i was constantly breaking
things oh my gosh yeah we pick that up
i'm pretty sure yeah but it was pretty
cool i mean i'm glad it turned out well
i'm very proud to love that it was done
with a fanny pack there's nothing
funnier and more awesome i just love
that it's a fanny pack um i also love
the goonies and i know that you're
probably like we're still talking about
this and yes we are um because it's one
of my like it's one of the films that
shaped me as a child i love it and i've
had like i feel like three or four cast
members now on my show which i'm very
lucky exactly josh brolin was just here
anyway so steven spielberg cast you in
that right away right yeah this was
right after indiana jones which i loved
thank you thank you yeah and i remember
i heard the pitch from steven spielberg
for the very first time i walked in his
office and as always he greets me with a
big smile and a big hug oh and he says
key i got your next movie
and it's called the goonies and it's
about seven kids finally a treasure map
and they're going this amazing adventure
what you didn't even have to audition no
no yeah cause i i ordered your audition
for indiana jones oh my gosh and uh and
he told me that i was gonna play data
who is a james bond double07 character
yeah who has all these cool gadgets that
jacket yes but they never work unless
my life depends on it and uh and sure
enough a few months later yeah i was on
the set with six of the kids
standing in front of a giant
breathtaking full-size pirate ship oh my
gosh and it was just incredible it's
like camp for kids yeah
did you ever did you keep anything from
like oh my god you know how i know i
would have kept everything but i did
keep the the dating jacket which is one
of the coolest things which is the best
part yeah yeah we open your jacket and
then it attaches the trash can and it's
raining i love the whole thing
um okay so every oh no i definitely have
seen it a thousand times so everyone
also knows you as shorty from indiana
jones as well which you've been in such
epic films like right off the bat at
such a young age so do you remember
working with harrison ford or yeah oh my
god it was incredible you were just
awesome people right off the bat yeah
well yeah first time ever right uh yeah
he was incredible he was like one of the
most generous down-to-earth human beings
i've ever met yes and i remember we shot
a lot of the exterior stuff in sri lanka
and we all stayed in this hotel and
every day after we wrapped we would go
and hang out at the swimming pool yeah
and when harrison ford found out that i
didn't know how to swim he says keith
come on let me teach you so to this day
i learned how to swim was because
madison ford taught you how to swim yeah
what is your life
i think you had a swim instructor at the
wires
wait what that's crazy i love that that
because it's not always that way for
kids like starting out like i love that
that was such a positive experience
right off the bat that's so cool i got
really lucky i mean who would have
thought right yeah i mean get to work
with i mean steven spielberg george
lucas
you're touched by god um so so you and
you're also talented that's the main
reason but you also fell in love with
taekwondo while doing the film right
yeah on indiana jones yeah uh you know
they had a sharing her and i had so much
fun beating up bad guys in the movie
yeah that after the movie i i you know i
took training seriously i studied
taekwondo for many years wow that's so
cool
i love that well that's important
because like we just saw you use martial
arts in this film so everything it's
called everything everywhere all at once
and so tell me more about it like why
are you such a badass with a fanny pack
well first of all
it's a it's a big science fiction action
drama comedy
and and and it's about a family who are
disconnected with each other and they
have to journey far far into the
multiverse to find themselves again
and uh and and it's a great movie about
what ifs and what would our lives could
have been like how we you know make
different choices in our life and it's
highly original very inventive written
and directed by the daniels uh it's with
michelle yo jamie lee curtis james hong
i mean the movie is incredible and i
can't by god yeah
i get to be part of this after a 20-year
hiatus from acting i love that though
that's so you know why you're just
waiting for those really awesome roles
now i'm just gonna wait for these really
awesome roles to land here um well the
new movie is amazing everybody has to go
see there's more than just the awesome
fanny pack moment um it's called
everything everywhere all at once and
it's in theaters nationwide right now
y'all gotta check it out
[Music]
you